your work with tom
has been like really fantastic and i
know you guys have talked about
uh going to space with something in the
future
i've wanted to know since i heard about
this how do you get insurance
to film something in space who's going
to be the one who who uh
who you know lets you film this thing
from the first
conversations we've had about the film
they
how you ensure it has been um
a central part of the conversations so
we we wouldn't be talking about this
movie if we hadn't figured out a way
um to to navigate the insurance
component
so we have navigated it but it was that
was
there would not have been a conversation
about this movie without figuring out
the insurance
that that's my biggest thing is how did
you guys solve that i won't i won't ask
any further
it's the same thing on lockdown it was
you know the
one of the first conversations was about
insurance because of the pandemic i mean
it is
sadly we're in a you know it's a
you can't make a movie without having an
insurance conversation
completely and you're trying by going to
outer space you're talking about
shooting and the heart
you know in london in the heart of the
pandemic you know
insurance is going to dictate whether
that actually is possible
is that something that you guys think
you're going to be filming within the
next year
two years is it like on the immediate oh
yeah yeah
it's it's it's yeah i mean it's it's not
just some abstract ideas
it's a movie got it do you know do you
guys have a title or
not yet not yet have you figured out um
what you're going to do next uh do you
know what your
2021 is looking like i'm not sure any of
us really know
what 2021 is going to look like yet it's
you know there's
uh because because of of the pandemic
um i have something i'm working on that
i don't
i i'm hoping i can shoot but
i i don't think anyone can
can know a hundred percent right now for
what i'm trying to do